по луках це поїздку штату міністра
закордонних справ павла клімкіна
підготовку офіційного візиту
президента України в США та яких значних
результаті перчик і зайти в українську
високого суду актив то сша за чеком це
на у роті
здається експерти crh її візиту
знайомства інала більше не нових
контактів
вони ж у гори не конкретних намагай
україну чеку і на сам політ заспа кльові
сигнали збоку нового американського до
ревниво українську раду на я пішла виші
пара каната себе у тому що але war
міністрація США десна травня на світ
продовжив цю політику адміністрації
обами щодо мінських у ось і що
адміністрація трампу і чи треба йому Петро
у цьому і українок що не будете подалі
шукала тебе на донбасі а бик що росія
7 теда тревал це задумував вона стоїть
думаю на небагато не згадувати і в тому
краще буду адміністрації трампу та
яким а ось цю політику вдома з
рукою та перспективою найвідомішого
нитковий єна заради найважливішим для
кривих ства україни
шукаю правда годину для везуть це США
браун і налипла на думку експертів бата
чи світлових дарує на роззяв у тебе
класні свої візити
до вашингтона, оскільки бог ще вбив олу
будинку повно і не ви значилися за крима і
міжнародних мінос і нах але думка
американський експорт екіпу над людиною
стали тягуча політика вашингтону
потрібно місити ще бог краси сажки
вектори сонячної політики
нової адміністрації безодні штати дружини
молитви значущі сонячну політику та
тему плані україна можна його кров aqua
party
за рану стартуєш замша у боці дроту
раннього старту полежавши допомогою можна
3 повним чином і в полоні ти на процес
ви значення c і політики ви ніч з
мінуса тому частіше не всі кадри
при значенні на свої посади одеси через
посмішки дякувати за словами у
українських дипломатів до і в затікала наю
тому ще стригтиму трампа і порошенка
битву лосяра не shiny shoe stretch
трампа і путіна сама туману хочеш у
старовину ту провести за
адже бачили в США то українці до саміту
вилітають двадцятку черні